I want to compliment you you come
bursting out here and you you are
ageless I have been interviewing you
since my show began in 1993 this guy
does not age you pop out here you're
dancing you're filled with energy what
is your secret jeff goldblum what do you
do I have no secret I have no secret
sleep I like sleep I think you're just
nodded off almost for a second there I
thought you were going to sleep no I
went to and dude do a deep reflective
place oh you oh I could answer you
truthfully no yes and I took a nap today
yeah you take it an that you'd like a
nice nap I do like a nap if I can get a
nap but around here it's very hard a lot
of decisions I'm sure I made that up
there's really nothing to do here well
do you have a do you have a place where
you can be comfortable and a sweet sweet
spot what do you mean a sweet sweet spot
I have a dread I have a dressing room
Andy and I have dressing rooms near each
other and sometimes if we're done going
over all the comedy and there's a little
time left if I can get like even 20
minutes that resets the computer sure it
does yeah but here's my question like
try and take care of myself but I am
rotting like a pumpkin in the Sun I am
no no no this is all lighting and makeup
swear to God and if you see me in real
life I look like the Chucky doll it's a
horror show you I've seen you in person
you look fantastic you must be using
creams ointments I use nothing well I
use nothing nor do I wear any makeup and
I and I don't wear makeup
no no credit no makeup and I just wash
my face maybe that's the key I mean you
look fantastic and no no no it's about
this this is yeah it's not girl I think
maybe a change of mind I think you could
change your mind about that I'll bet you
look fantastic I'll bet you're wrong you
know what he looks like
I'll bet Andy tell him it's like Miss
Havisham he's not helping
[Laughter]
look it up now get out it is you have an
olive complexion yeah always kind of you
don't need makeup but he and I need
makeup because we're like we're like the
color of legal paper yeah
no way that's true and also I think when
you open it when you open a can of spam
yeah and you plop it out onto a plate
and you put it out in the Sun that's my
thigh at the beach you know seriously
and and and so you have that great
complexion which is why you mean you
could be any age right now you could you
may be in your late 80s but I will never
know that because you look eternally
young thank you very much
no but I say if I could put one more
word in for embracing nature embracing
nature and don't mask nature what do you
mean don't wear Nikes saying going
around naked yeah cuz look may I could
[ __ ] let me try to change your mind
about your glasses at me
he just contemptuously tossed his
glasses that there was no contempt
you're projecting that entirely
ask me how I enjoyed the party last
night jack enjoy the party left it was
pretty good god I wish I had these
glasses yeah what do you mean a don't
master nature well I think you're wrong
about that you need all this help sorry
Oh for God again I think he's away from
you I'll have these you gave you gave
the child his toy and well I you know
you look good to me now you know why
your clear glasses wise yeah but but
they're blurry so I need that's why I
take them off when I want to look at you
yeah here keep this closed yo I say
let's let's look at this okay this is
your skin without makeup yes I say it's
good
no yes yeah that's first the hand the
hand isn't it good I'm done this before
[Applause]
I have a little prehensile redtail in
the back I've got a nice hairy smaller
back there take a look up close really
check it out
oh look at that these are the least
professional interviews I ever had
apologize I say get your face to look
like that and like that
wait no you want to look like my ass
Noir and beauty anything to your hair
hair is what God gave me
color wise no look at it it's fantastic
but cut color whines oh yeah I'm a dark
dark dark hair there's not a gray hair
in your head no it's fantastic really
fantastic yeah really
yeah you wouldn't be contradicted if we
happen to see the carpet does it match
it it matches the drapes
[Applause]
this for our viewers
my favorite moment of Hajj you know I
you know I never knew it was shaved into
a heart I apologize to everyone this
probably won't air
we'll be right back more with Jeff
Goldblum
[Applause]
you